Tom Verducci joins us on short notice
and Tom on short of sleep as well Tom
thank you for getting up early joining
us I know you're headed to Houston here
how would you summarize last night's
game I mean I go back to Game four of 93
remember that
Phillies Blue Jays game 4:14 yeah I
remember a guy stood up is it the old
vet Stadium had a sign they could have
used last night that will pitch middle
relief for food anybody get anybody out
keep the ball in the ballpark so as I
was entertaining it was one of the
craziest World Series games I can
remember second-guessing has it started
and does it continue with any moves made
last night yeah I think whenever you run
games the way the Dodgers do where they
kept their starting pitchers out so
quickly because they want to get to the
bullpen you know kind of analytical
thing at third time around the lineup
you're better off the first harm than a
starting pitcher
once you start that carousel going he's
getting to that bullpen that quickly you
start running out of options now in Dave
Roberts defense he did get the game to
the best closer in baseball with one run
lead in the ninth inning and it's new
off with one swing my Marwin Gonzalez
but I think that's probably where the
second-guessing is you know did he give
her till I was game too early would be
too quick to go to that old pen all
right we always talk about momentum is
the next day's starting pitching if
that's the case
who's got the momentum going into Game
three in Houston well in this case I
would say momentum last night except to
his home field I mean that Minute Maid
Park is just been crazy loud the team
defense of the office of the Astros has
been much better in that ballpark you
know it starting pitching wise I would
probably get darvis and edge slightly
but I think at home the Astros have been
a much more dangerous offensive team and
you know they get a little bit of mojo
back last night late well you know
starting in the eighth inning obviously
that they I expect them to carry into
Game three so I'd say momentum
with Houston right now coming back home
better game game 1 or game 2 you know I
heard you say that's your poll question
that is a great question uh I'll say
this I thought he one was a better
baseball game I mean there are people in
the Astro side said that was the best
that they've ever seen
Clayton Kershaw I'm saying a lot well
last night was a more memorable game
we'll be talking about this game 10 20
30 years from now I'm not sure we'd say
that of our game one well we want
shorter games but shorter games mean
less action you had an extra inning game
and you went and let another hour or so
hour and a half more with last night's
game
I love last night because the home runs
meant something and they came at clutch
times and that's different than having a
slugfest where it's an 8 to 2 game and
you know you have you know eight home
runs yeah great point I mean listen we
all know this is a record-setting year
four home runs more than six thousand
and I thought about Sandy Koufax walked
in that game right today Koufax gave up
two home runs his entire postseason
career basically all world series
there's no point last night were 5 out
of 13 fly balls were whole months and if
you just felt like in anybody keep the
ball in the yard here now I agree with
you that is exciting because they were
meaningful homeruns
you know tying games coming back into
the game putting a lead putting your
team lead so they were not meaningless
hold on what's tack on home runs there's
a lot of nothing game but I would warm
another hot night in LA in a year with a
ball slide where every pitcher will tell
you the ball is juiced this is a game
baseball wanted right yeah we're offense
back in the game or home runs you know a
lot of it but also how much did the
weather have to do with those home runs
drifting out not all them you know
Justin Turner did say his home brought
in Game one probably is not a home on a
typical cool night in Dodger Stadium 103
you're going to get a little more carry
so you know some of those are absolute
bombs that we saw last night so I don't
think maybe another one maybe of the
eight last night
no I think it's just the way the game is
now I think the ball does carry I think
you know hitters are listen nobody wants
to hit a ground ball today's camp it was
very different from where it was ten
years ago with people trying to win
batting titles people don't care about
that entitles now hmm everybody wants
the slug so it's all about getting the
ball in the air safe travels to Houston
I'll leave you with this the yasiel puig
stuff at the plate and the bad flip and
lickin the bad and it feels like the
Astros sort of grabbed this and made it
their own
is this is this a thing that you we
should be watching for now as we move
forward I think it's good-natured though
there okay I'm a thing where it you know
in your face and this is all about me
showing up your pitcher or your bench
you know creo last night said listen the
only other time that's lift was during
the WDC and he's not that kind of player
I don't think it was a response to a
deal what he was doing I kind of dig it
though I think I like it when the
players are showing most and conviction
spots in the game and again and one's
not showing up the other team I got no
problem with it and hopefully there's a
day and it was an issue just in terms of
people asking the players have to begin
but I hope we get a time where we don't
have to ask I say were you upset by so
long do not rubbing it in Tom thank you
we appreciate you getting up early safe
travels to Houston that's Tom Verducci
MLB on Fox reporter and analyst for the
Major League Baseball Network analyst
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]